is it legalistic for women of God to not cut their hair
this is a question that I get asked a lot
alongside the question of
is it legalistic for women to only wear skirts and dresses
and my answer is simply no
if you have a personal conviction to not cut your hair
or a personal conviction to only wear skirts and dresses
that's amazing
but what is legalistic is pushing that belief on other women of God
who have studied scripture and prayed things out for themselves
I know so many incredible women of God who cut their hair and wear pants
and still carry a great anointing of the Holy Spirit
and that's because our identity is found in Christ
not clothing or material things